نبدا بالتطورات في البرازيل فقد اقتحم
محتجون مؤيدونا للرئيس البرازيلي السابق
جوير بونس نارو اقتحموا القصر الرئاسي
ومقر الحكومه وكذلك مبنى البرلمان ومبنى
المحكمه الفيديراليه في العاصمه برازيليه
وذلك رفضا لتنصيب الرئيس لولا دا سيلفا
وتخلل الاقتحام وقوع مواجهاتهم بين
المحتجين والشرطه وقطع المحتجون عددا من
الطرق في برازيليا واستخدمته قوه الشرطه
الغاز المثيره للدموع لتفريقيا المحتجين
جدير بالذكر ان الرئيس ولد سيلفا غير
موجود داخل القصر الرئاسي في برازيليا حيث
يزوروا ولايه سوفاوله
هذا وكان الرئيس السابق جرير بورسونارو قد
خسر الانتخابات امام منافسه الزعيم اليسار
نهايه اكتوبر الماضي وغادر البلاد عشيه
حفل التنصيب دون تهنئه خصمه وتسليمه
الشعره الرئاسيه
الجزيره حسان مسعود حسان ضعنا في سوره
الواقعه
عبد القادر في هذه اللحظات
تجري عمليات اقتحام من قبل مؤيدين للرئيس
السابق
برسونارو في العاصمه البرازيليه
البرازيليه للمقار الحكوميه الرئيسيه
الثلاث في وسط العاصمه البرازيليه وهي مقر
الحكومه الرئيسيه والقصر الرئاسي الذي
يدير فيه الرئيس البرازيلي شؤون البلاد في
العاصمه البرازيليه
ومبنى البرلمان الفيدراليه في العاصمه
البرازيليه وكذلك مبنى المحكمه الفدراليه
العليا في هذه اللحظات يقوم محتجون
مؤيدونا للرئيس السابق جيرمن
لتنصيب الرئيس اليسرى الذي كان قد تم
تنصيبه الاحد الماضي للمره الثالثه في
تاريخه يقومون باقتحام هذا المبنى
ورصدت الصور التي
انتشرت من داخل ال- مقر الحكوميه الرئيسيه
الثلاث تكسير وتحطيم للاثاث والمقتنيات في
داخل هذه المباني الحكوميه الثلاث
بالاضافه الى محاولات تخريب لهذه المباني
وهمم جلوس همم
المحتاجين على
الكراسي الرئيسيه همم
لاداره ورئاسه البرلمان الفيدرالي
البرازيلي في مشهد يذكرنا بما حدث في
الكونجرس الامريكي همم بعد خساره دونالد
ترامب للانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه هذا
المشهد كان همم يخشى ان يحدث وان تشهده
البرازيل بعد خساره الرئيس اليمنيه شهير
في نهايه اكتوبر الماضي امام امام منافسه
الزعيم اليسا في الانتخابات الا ان همم
الاوضاع كانت ما زالت تحت السيطره خلال
الفتره الماضيه
واستطاعت قوات الامن امن ان تمنع حدوث مثل
هذه الاحداث خلال الفتره الماضيه وشهدت
طرقات عديده في البرازيل قطع للطرقات ومنع
لي الحركه عند الطرقات الرئيسيه التي تربط
ما بين الولايات البرازيليه ولكن هذه
الحركه ايضا كانت توقفت بعد دعوه من
الرئيس السابق جير برسونارو لفتح الطرقات
لانصاره الا ان هذه الاحداث عادت لتظهر
مره اخرى هناك في العاصمه الا البرازيليه
كما في عدد من المدن البرازيليه بما فيها
همم ولايه ساقوله التي يدعو فيها في هذه
الاثناء مؤيدوه سونار وليل الخروج الى
الشوارع وتحديدا الى المناطق المحيطه
بالثقنات العسكريه لمطالبه الجيش الموجود
من استمرار حكم اليسار مجددا
نعم الرئيس الولاده سيلفا كان قد غادر
العاصمه برازيليه صباحا اليوم وتوجه الى
ولايه ساو باولو وتحديدا الى مدينه
اراكورا هذه المدينه الواقعه في المناطق
الريفيه لسوفاول وكانت قد شهدت
امطار غزيره ادت الى مقتل خمسه اشخاص توجه
الرئيس لولا الى هناك للطلاع على احوال
هذه المدينه وهذه البلده في داخل ولايه
سوف باولو
وحدثت هذه الاحداث في ظل غياب الرئيس لولا
عن العاصمه برازيليا حتى هذه اللحظه لم
تعلن الرئاسه او الجهات الامنيه عن مكان
وجود الرئيس البرازيلي الوضع سيلفا في
ولايه سوف اقول نحن همم على همم على علم
البيئه انه لم يعد الى عاصمه البرازيل
البرازيليه ما زال في ولايه سابالو الا ان
كان مكانه بشكل واضح ليس همم معلومه حتى
هذه اللحظه من الجدير همم ذكره ايضا عبد
القادر ان المبنى الذي تم اقتحامه في
برازيليا هو مبنى اداره الحكم هو الرئاسيه
التي تدار منه البلاد الا ان قصر رئاسيا
اخرا هو القصر الذي يسمى قصر الالفورادا
هو الذي يقيم فيه الرئيس همم لولا دا
سيلفا او رئيس الجمهوريه البرازيليه بشكل
عام وهذه المنطقه حتى هذه اللحظه لم
يستطعم المحتجون ان يصلوا اليها ولكن بكل
الاحوال فان هذا المشهد همم هو همم مشهد
همم
يشير الى حاله من التوتر تعيشها البرازيل
كانت مرتقبه كان هناك خشيه من ان تحدث
ولكنها حدثت اليوم بعد اسبوع على تنصيب
الرئيس لولا ده سيلفا وسفر الرئيس السابق
عشيه التنصيب دون مشاركته بحفل التنصيب او
تسليمه لشاره الرئاسه وكذلك دون تهنئه
الرئيس حتى هذه اللحظه لم يعلن بشكل واضح
عن قبوله بالهزيمه وعن تهنيئته للرئيس
الفائز كما جاء